hello everyone i'm john noll governor of
the academy's visual effects branch
on behalf of fellow branch governors
craig barron and robredo
i'm excited to welcome you to the visual
effects bake off
one of the things that uh that i
particularly liked was uh
uh or thought was really clever was the
um
the adding value to big wide
establishing geography shots to expand
the world want to comment on on that
process
uh yeah the the map paintings and the 3d
work for um environments was it was
spread
fairly few and far between and it was
striking a balance of
it was sort of like the scale thing in
the hobbit of just
giving the audience a nudge reminding
them every now and then
working out the timings of when we
needed to do that and
and a couple of late editions you know
right at the end of the show that we had
to really cram through in the last
couple of weeks
just to just to bring it up to keep it
consistent right through the entire
movie
something that i thought was really
intriguing um in the real was
the need to do a digital felicity jones
uh due to from production logistics i
think we were we were looking at the
early r d that we did for
um for that digi double and starting to
feel pretty good about it
around the same time that we were
looking at how to shoot all of the zero
g
which was obviously a headache that
we've had before and
and it felt like this time around we'd
be able to use the technology
to um enable that shoot to be simplified
which was a huge huge win for the
production i think it was um uh
it really helped to be able to for all
the cast not just felicity to be able to
kind of
contain them their zero g work to more
or less just close-ups and have max's
team
animate the bodies and and um within
reason the faces
for the rest
um in the imperial city it looks like
you're shooting on a
on a set or a location kind of looks
already like the
imperial palace there can you tell me
about what's what's going on there
we were able to shoot at a location that
had some
stuff in it that we ended up replacing
like we'd have like
uh one of our locations had a palace but
it was the wrong palace so we put a full
palace over that
so we went over and um whether's onset
team went
and scanned the entire park so that we
could
create completely digital versions of
all of those backgrounds as well as
creating the wider city environment from
building blocks that we created out of
chopping up those scans what about the
[Music]
others
one of the the big challenges on the
film like this is you're trying to do
very
naturalistic looking animals so
can you comment on the process of
finding that balance
it's a balance between you know finding
the performances in the animals the
natural
movements in the animals and behaviors
and and adding our
our element of uh performance
mainly through the eyes it's speaking
through ivan you know the key
to iron was giving that performance
through the eyes we can tell a story and
tell his emotion
watching the film was how many places
there
are what appeared to be pretty free
handheld cameras
traveling through an environment that
also include
backwards elements in them i was
wondering if you could comment on the
methodology employed there the fords and
reverse
people are all in camera so the actors
and the extras essentially learned how
to perform in
backwards by filming themselves forwards
reversing it and then copying that
action so
we would always try and film the most
difficult thing to perform backwards
the right way and then reverse and
possibly reverse the whole thing so that
the people who were supposed to be
forwards when they're
congratulations nominees for your moving
miracles they propelled the art and
science of cinema storytelling forward
they guarantee a future of infinite
creative possibility for filmmakers
everywhere
you